so tell me are you a loyal Scott yet oh
yes definitely and how come you became a
loyal Scott well I think I was a loyal
Scott before the program actually
started I got a lot of my experience at
CMU and it's a way to give back and stay
in touch so tell me how you use your CMU
experience in the work world basically I
think my education gave me an approach
to problem solving and work is just a
bunch of problem solving so how can an
alumnus give back to the University you
think whether some of the ways there's a
number of ways you can volunteer whether
it's through the admissions area or
through a local chapter or you know
other things you can do is just come
back and be an advocate for the
university tell your friends how great a
place it is tell prospective students
what a great place it is okay and how do
you like to show your tart and pride
what's your favorite way well my family
seems to think that a good gift for me
is something tartan so I have a Scottie
dog I have a bauble Scottie dog
bobblehead and just recently my niece
gave me and I'm not sure she got it
through Carnegie Mellon but to glass
Scottie dog bookends what would you
advise a young person coming to Carnegie
Mellon what do they need to know about
our school they need to know that it's
it's a school with a lot of type a
people who really get into whatever it
is they choose to do there's a lot of
opportunities for you to express
yourself and explore a lot of areas and
you should take advantage of it